[Music]
the invention of polyurethanes
skateboard wheels in the early 1970s
suddenly made jumps in tight cornering
possible because these wheels had a
better grip on riding surfaces than the
old metal or ceramic wheels they were
more durable and the shock absorption
was greatly improved skateboard wheels
come in different sizes hardness colors
and graphic designs for the rider there
are many practical and aesthetic
considerations making skateboard wheels
starts with the computer design a
designer uses the software to guide
cutting tools the tools carve into a
solid aluminum puck and transform it
into one half of a wheel mold next the
other half the mold takes shape as the
computerized tolling sculpts another
puck to a profile that fits to the first
one perfectly
[Music]
not all of the skateboard wheel molds
are two-part versions others are
one-piece structures each with the pin
in the center to form a bearing cavity a
nozzle dispenses freshly mixed
polyurethane liquid into the wheel molds
the liquid starts to solidify
immediately
to complete the process a worker loads
the polyurethane filled molds into an
oven and bakes them at almost 240
degrees Fahrenheit for 40 minutes during
baking any bubbles in the polyurethane
rise to the top and are diffused leaving
solid forms with no weak spots workers
remove the pins from the molds then it's
on to the next station here a worker
blasts compressed air between the wheels
and the molds to pry the wheels free and
pop them out another worker probes the
wheel using the durometer gauge to
insure the urethane has cured to the
right degree of hardness if the sample
wheel is sufficiently hard the batch is
ready for the next step the worker
clamps the skateboard wheel in a lathe
the lathe spins the wheel while an
automatic cutter contours the edges to a
softer more rounded profile to give the
skateboard wheels some visual impact an
artist selects and arranges graphic
designs on a computer he prints a film
negative of the images he's chosen a
worker will use this negative to produce
a printing plate from a piece of metal
that's been coated with a
light-sensitive substance known as
emulsion he places the film negative on
the plate inside a UV light chamber he
closes the lid and activates the UV
light this triggers a photochemical
reaction that transfers the image from
the negative to the plate the worker
then applies a solution that removes
unexposed emulsion and in the process
H's the image into the printing plate
he rinses off the chemicals
[Music]
next he dries the plate to reveal the
etched artwork another worker positions
that magnetized ink up over the image
and installs it in a pad printing
machine
[Music]
an operator loads skateboard wheels onto
posts that index them forward for
printing the ink up deposits ink on the
printing plate a silicon pad picks up
the inked image and stamps it onto the
skateboard wheel the operator removes
the printed wheel and sets it on a tray
a technician now clamps one of the
wheels in a testing device which will
gauge the rebound he drops a metal ball
onto the wheel and measures how high it
bounces or rebounds a high rebound is
desirable these skateboard wheels are
now cleared for shipping a worker wraps
the wheels in plastic and heat shrinks
it it takes about three days to make
these skateboard wheels but how long the
last depends a lot on the rider and how
he or she rolls
[Music]